[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
so
to
[Laughter]
do
so
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
me
hey here we are once again yeah it's
wednesday
i know
that's it yeah we have the same shirt on
oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] i didn't realize that
matchy-matchy yeah we didn't coordinate
before it's just
i make so many of them so dorky i got
like two i got like three of these i
made and
like three piskins and i got a lot of
[ __ ]
where where are we where i wear my own
clothes well yeah i mean you know
they're wearing somebody well like i
said it's like you know what we we order
shirts like to print them for you guys
and it's like so
like i'm gonna mix kind of stuff for me
yeah we make several of ours they're
like uniforms
like work uniforms
we saw a movie last night it was a good
one the thing is though is that i missed
most of it i had to cook
yeah he was cooking i was cooking up red
beans and rice man they had ham hocks in
there
[ __ ] i posted that [ __ ] i didn't post
what it looked like it was done i should
have done that because i made a good
bowl again well you could
sell it i'll take him to the pitch later
like when you make that yeah because we
saw
i mean he made we have one of those pi
how many gallons is that pot
that's like a chicken that's a 10 gallon
big restaurant pot yeah he made like a
huge
that size pie no five gallons okay five
gallons
probably three probably more like three
i don't know it looks like a lot now
it's three gallons probably three
because i don't know three gallons of
red i had a bowl of it yesterday and i
had a bowl of it for lunch today had
[ __ ] ham hocks in it and and dewey's
sausage this [ __ ] was cajun style it's
got the cajun seasoning in there
and uh i was making had a nice little
[ __ ] bowl for presentation i was
putting the damn
packing cups full of rice and then that
makes let's say you have to like the
little
little rice [ __ ] thing right around
the rice temple
putting [ __ ] parsley on it and salt
and [ __ ] i think it was pretty
oh yeah it was beautiful oh man it's
just like it tastes great and delicious
yeah i know i'm gonna yeah we have some
more of that later
yeah no no i gotta we got that pizza
crust oh yeah
yeah because like i said if he's going
to cook a bunch of stuff he'll cook like
a couple things like better yeah gonna
sustain us over the next few days
yeah so we have so many red beans and
rice and also so much pizza oh and sauce
yeah we don't have to eat all the red
beans and rice i might freeze some of it
yeah cause that is kind of a lot of it
yeah it is yeah
i mean it'll take me a while to get sick
of it because i don't usually get sick
of that but man i had it again this
morning i was like
i forgot how good this was shoveling
that [ __ ]
it's even better than the second day
yeah well kind of it kind of um
kind of cures yeah it's kind of like
indian food that's the same thing
yeah indian food is always best like the
second or third day
after you make it third day is really
good because it seems like all the
spices like kind of
meld all together so yeah just so we
were saying that because we always end
up talking about food don't we
yeah um because you were just kind of
like in and out like watching
but i sat and watched the whole i got to
see it again man it was [ __ ] good
i really liked this movie it's really
soundtrack it's weird because
it seems like it's gotten kind of like
mixed reviews although
um you know the horror media like
rumored magazine and stuff like that
they seem to like really dig it which
you know but i there was something about
this one
that i really really liked and that
really and i can't quite put my finger
on what it was i mean there was a lot of
things
and this actually gave me some really
creepy
dreams which a lot of horror movies
don't do like not nightmares necessarily
but they gave me some really unsettling
dreams i can't like remember what they
were but they were kind of like related
to what the movie
had a really good tone and this the um
uh i liked uh the the acting yeah and
how the story was going
but i kept having to step out so i was
missing it every time i come back and be
something [ __ ] weird happened
it's like what the [ __ ] you know that's
a it's like man it had an 80s vibe
yeah it kind of reminded me of kind of
like an old school horror version with a
lot of practical effects but like a
whole
an an old-school horror version of say
like um
um you know blood machines yeah imagine
if you were going to do that in a horror
movie
but not all so visual that's quite so
overt sure
right but you know what i'm talking
about it it was kind of like that same
vibe behind it yeah rue morgan called it
like comic book meets giallo
yeah with like a new retro i mean the
score of this
i love the score yeah i have to say and
i really really liked
the look of it too it's called random
acts of violence in case you didn't know
it just dropped on shutter
it's actually canadian um it actually
premiered at
one like a horror film festival late
last year like i believe in fall of 2019
but it wasn't actually released in
canada until this summer and then
uh it made its debut in the united
states
uh just like less than a week ago on
shutter
now what this is so
random act of violence i guess was a
comic book
that came out in 2010 i don't think it
was a series i think it was just like a
standalone
comic book or graphic novel um and it
was written by
uh jimmy palmiotti and justin gray
now they apparently had been trying to
get a movie version
of this graphic novel off the ground
since 2011 and they had like all the
you know screenplay written everything
like that but for whatever reason you
know like
indie films you know money raising and
[ __ ] like that
it actually didn't get made until
recently
but i mean okay so the story behind this
is that the main character whose name is
todd
he has apparently he has written a very
successful
indie comic called slasher man which has
been going i believe they say in the
movie that has been going for 10 years
and it's actually based on a real killer
the i-90 killer now i was thinking oh is
that that's a real killer i was thinking
of the i-70 killer there's so many like
highway serial killers that i was like
confusing them so the i-90 killer i
don't think is like a real person
that's the i70 killer and they caught
that guy but this guy
in the universe of the movie is a real
serial killer
and his thing was that he would be
killing people
um along this particular stretch of
highway and he would
do like really horrible um like poses
with the bodies like almost in like an
artistic
kind of thing so the so in the universe
of the movie these
are real murders but this main character
todd
has made a career out of doing this
slasher man
comic series based on those real murders
you know what i'm saying yeah now so
what ends up happening over the course
of the thing is like so he
it's been 10 years uh the you know the
comic book has been very successful
but he's like wanting to wrap it up but
he can't get any ideas
for the last uh issue like he wants it
to be like a big deal he wants to be
meaningful
so he's kind of looking for an angle and
he can't really think of anything like
he's you know having some writer's block
or whatever
so his publisher ezra who's actually
played by
the director uh jay barachel
he suggests why don't we go on like kind
of a press tour like a little press tour
like a road trip
um and we'll go around to all these
places where
this serial killer used to hunt and
you know we'll interview people and [ __ ]
like that and maybe you'll be inspired
you know to can and we'll do like radio
interviews and [ __ ] like that along the
way like to plug your [ __ ] and
everything
now it so happens too that todd's
girlfriend kathy is also writing a book
about the i-90 killer but more from
the victim's perspective like she wants
like you know to tell the victim stories
whereas he's kind of more so there's not
i don't want to say that the movie has
like a message necessarily but one
theme of the movie is that you know
where where do you draw the line between
you know
art and exploitation
and you know how much responsibility say
does an artist have for
you know inspiring real crimes that's
like something
the movie doesn't come down on either
side of the issue or anything but it's
that's kind of like the thematic uh
thrust that it's like exploring
because one because when they start out
on this
journey like this road trip um the
serial killer
that's that slash remain is based on has
been um
you know has been inactive for many many
years
but when they start going out on this
road trip and they start getting some
um you know blow back from these towns
where they go to because a lot of the
people like
you know he goes to this radio interview
in this small town
and the guy who's interviewing him for
the radio show knew
one of the victims and is like really
upset that
todd is making all of this money as he's
seeing it from
exploiting the victims of these crimes
and making the
killer into the hero essentially so
that's kind of like
so he's starting to like question like
what the [ __ ] am i doing and
all this other [ __ ] now it so happens
that as they start out on this
tour the serial killer or a copycat
uh becomes active once again and seems
to be following
this group and staging
uh these elaborate murders that
uh were drawn in the comic book you know
what i mean
so he starts like following them and
you know murdering people again like
close to them like in
and you don't really fit i don't want to
spoil the ending but like
um i guess he's trying to
you know it's ooh it's hard to say
without i can't comment on this [ __ ]
because i i didn't i couldn't see it all
but every time i popped in man it was
looking [ __ ] really good
and i really liked the score which gave
me a real good
if when the score is good chances are
the movie's good
and it's just something i've noticed um
because it shows that a lot of care was
put into the movie like
i guess it kind of every time i the vibe
i get
every time i go in there and [ __ ] see
some of it is that it kind of it's kind
of how i would imagine the dudes who did
blood machines what if they tried to
make an 80s style [ __ ] horror
movie yeah and that but without all
those visual effects just
straight like like they were trying to
make a [ __ ] um
a carpenter style horror movie or
something like that
that's what it kind of seemed like yeah
i really like this they knew the genre
i really liked the visual aesthetic of
this movie like we said it's not like
super over the top like blood machines
or anything but it was kind of like
i loved that a lot of the shots had like
this
really pretty like bright green
cast but then there'd be like little
glows of like
of like gold and red so it was almost
kind of like almost like i said almost
like a giallo movie in the way that it
was shot like the
the shots of it was really really
beautiful yeah and it was
it was uh not
not like a horror comedy from the 80s it
was like it wasn't funny
yeah it was like a serious it's like a
serious horror movie from the 80s is
what it kind of felt like to me
the good part of the 80s not the bad
part of the 80s yeah this is
this was definitely not creepy [ __ ] yeah
this was definitely not a comedy
um it was v it's very very
violent it's very very brutal like the
crimes
are a little bit hard to watch um
the practical effects like the aftermath
of this because this killer his thing is
like these elaborate
murder set pieces like the way he poses
these bodies and sometimes it's multiple
bodies like
in these scenes like he's trying to like
make a statement with it yeah and these
little scenes that she's talking about
to me they reminded me
the ones that i saw i didn't get to see
them all but the ones that i saw kind of
reminded me of the scenes you would see
like something from [ __ ] hereditary
or heredity
hereditary reddit that was called yeah
remember they do the weird [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] bodies it kind of was
reminding me that wasn't it hereditary
what was that yeah we didn't have didn't
they have that damn body up on [ __ ]
on the
like on a cross and the head was on
[ __ ] backwards oh yeah i guess
yeah see i know what i'm talking about
well it wasn't that's not like the first
thing that i think of i think when you
think of hereditary you think of that
like that little girl's head with the
ants all over and stuff like that
yeah no i was thinking about towards the
end you know when they had had the [ __ ]
yeah with the cults and everything
shines it's kind of like with the heads
yeah okay i got you yeah the piano wire
right right it just kind of reminded me
of that it was yeah so
so it always it always almost kind of
reminds me
sometimes
every now and then man [ __ ] all that
it actually kind of reminded me too of a
little bit like a um
silence of the lambs type thing just
not necessarily silence of the lambs but
maybe um
i don't know i guess maybe manhunter one
or one of those like thomas harris kind
of
stories with like a killer that would
like pose uh
would pose them like in an artistic
fashion quote unquote
so the uh so the practical effects in
this like the bodies like when they
when the police like find the bodies and
everything like that is pretty gnarly
so it's it's really really well done
like it really looks
super cool um it's kind of like like i
said it
it sort of starts out like i don't want
to say a murder mystery it kind of
starts out sort of like that but sort of
like a slasher and then it kind of goes
in a more like arty psychological
direction a little bit toward the end
just a little bit though it's not like
you know super hearty party or anything
rebecca's saying it sounds kind of like
the television series with [ __ ]
hannibal electric yeah yeah yeah that's
kind of what i was thinking about i've
seen a couple of episodes i'd say yeah
from what i saw a little bit like that
it is a little bit like that so i'm
thinking in particular of
one uh scene that was like the the
terrible triptych if you've seen the
movie you know what i'm talking about
um and you know there's one with like a
severed head and [ __ ] like that that's
really well done like i said it's
it's very violent it's pretty gory um
and it kind of has a lot like i said it
doesn't come down on one side of the
debate or the other
but it does kind of go a lot into you
know
how how culpable is this guy
that has made a career out of
drawing out of um you know making art
out of this dude's real crimes and
kind of fetishizing the victims
fetishizing
the killer um you know in his kind of
moral
culpability about that and then also his
girlfriend you know is she any better
because she's writing a book and even
though she's ostensibly
trying to focus on the victims is it any
better because she's still like hoping
to make money off of the
crimes and everything so it's i thought
it was kind of interesting from that
standpoint too because you could kind of
say the same thing about anybody that
writes
books about true crime that it's like
you know you
you could be said to be like making
money like exploiting the victims and
[ __ ] like that but like i said it's not
real
they don't you know push either agenda
like in the movie they
they're just kind of like that's the
theme that's like running throughout it
um because this killer is
directly um killing people and posing
them in the way that it was in the comic
book even though he had been killing
people ahead of like before that too
you know what i mean so it wasn't like
the guy with the cop that drew the comic
book was like making him do it
he was doing that prior to that but it
was just like it was like this weird
feedback loop
between the killer and the artist you
know what i mean so
that so i found that aspect like really
interesting
so as i said even though it took a long
time to get made and it seems like it's
gotten
you know fairly mixed reviews like some
people really seem to
have not liked it at all um in more
horror themed media
um it seems to be getting like better
reviews and like i said there was
something about it
that really that i really really liked
like there was just this
i think it was just kind of the perfect
combination of like
the aesthetic of it and the imagery
and the score and the characters there
was just something that
just clicked you know what i mean and
like i said for for a horror movie to
give me
to make me like dream about it is good
because that doesn't usually
happen like i said the last one that did
that was hereditary and that gave me
nightmares for like two weeks
at least the tv didn't turn on uh yeah
not
not it has done it again but not not
yesterday
when did it did it do it without you
telling me um no i told you about it but
it was like a few days ago
yeah it was a few days ago i think it
came on at 5
4 in the morning or five in the morning
something like that i was sleeping
just one time yeah i wasn't talking no
okay i don't think so
all right you're just like sleeping and
snoring or whatever i think i told you
and i thought you woke up but you didn't
remember afterwards
right so you know what i mean weird but
uh yeah so
like i said if you have shutter this is
one of the newest ones that they added
um i really
dug it your mileage may vary of course
like i said it's very
it's very gory and it's like pretty
brutal and pretty
violent um so if that's gonna bother you
but yeah i
i really liked it i thought it was
really good you know
so mango shutter watching list is
getting longer you got to get to work
dude
get there and start [ __ ] watching
them i tried i i say all this [ __ ]
i got a [ __ ] stack of [ __ ] yeah we
have a huge stack of
movies that we have we still haven't got
to but
that's the thing it's like i i do try to
like watch
all the new [ __ ] that they post um
you know i but i don't always have time
to do it and watching movies becomes
part of your job man [ __ ] it's it's
well yeah because a lot of times it's
like well i have a lot of i have to find
a new one to watch and then like we have
to find old ones like to watch for movie
retrospective and stuff although that's
that's not usually as hard because
usually that's a movie we've seen before
like you know it's not as much of a
problem and we know we're gonna like it
because that's why we picked it in the
first place
yeah oh i should also jump on that heavy
metal blu-ray
yeah we need to get on that too yeah
we'll uh haven't seen that [ __ ] forever
yeah that'll be that'll be one of the
ones we eventually review
i think it's on it's going to be on the
first poll which like i said i mentioned
it yesterday but if you're
gonna do retrospective on that one
that's what i said well it's it's on the
list
of the poll okay so if you want to see
us do heavy metal
like not this friday but the following
friday then go vote in the poll
like on friday you'll have like all
weekend i think i have it set
the poll will post this is for the movie
retrospective and for
um episode 212 or whatever the
one is after this saturday um i think
the the polls will both post on friday
and i think you'll have to like
sunday afternoon to like do them if
you're a patron so go in there and vote
and we'll see oh also what people are
saying though hold on what people are
saying is that shutter is available in
australia
this week yeah i heard that it just got
available there um
sydney lee uh she was at sydney sydney
um
sydney lane red member mountain and
liked it oh awesome
yeah that's awesome um oh also i wanted
to give a shout out to
links13 i don't know if she's here in
the comments she was here yesterday i
think who has
who became our newest patron yesterday
so thank you very much lynx13 if you're
out there watching
um but yeah i think that's probably all
oh i also want to say too that we
finally got around to watching the last
episode of
high score because remember we talked
about it like a couple days ago but we
only
but we'd only seen like the first last
step so it's good i think that was maybe
i don't know they were all pretty all
the episodes were pretty good but i
think the last one was probably the best
one because they were talking about the
transition
from uh you know 2d graphics to 3d
graphics so they talked about
castle wolfenstein and uh you know doom
and yeah um
and skyfox and all or star fox rather um
on nintendo like how they figured out
it was funny how they figured out how to
do 3d it's like almost all of it was
done by 18 year olds who were like
hacking into the [ __ ] yeah it's like
like opening the [ __ ] [ __ ] around
nintendo called him to japan they
thought they were probably gonna get
sued or something turned out they wanted
to know how they did that on a [ __ ]
game
on the gameboy and that uh they hired
him gave him a contract then he
segregated him from the rest of japanese
staff put him over on it
just put him down in the basement these
two british kids they're not gonna put
they're gonna put westerners around
japanese [ __ ] office workers
the [ __ ] bad habits will rub off on
them it probably will probably they're
much older too i would yeah
but yeah so they talked to they talked
extensively to the guy that um
that invented doom that's just one of
the guys it was actually two guys but i
guess they couldn't uh they couldn't get
an interview with the other guy that had
figured all the coding and stuff
but it's like because they're not only
the ones that figured out how to do
you know castle wolfenstein and uh and
doom and all that like in the 3d
environment like with all the textures
and everything
but they also figured out before they
did that they also figured out how to do
smooth side scrolling
on a pc because that was not a thing
because they said you know on nintendo
obviously when they play mario like it
was you know the side scrolling was very
you know fluid but they're like on a pc
it used to be
and i had totally forgotten it i forgot
about it it was like one screen and then
it went chunk
chunk it went like that like as you move
uh there's there's a [ __ ]
activision game called pitfall on atari
the original atari remember that
yeah yeah yeah just running pitfall yeah
yeah and evidently the whole [ __ ]
mario
side scrolling thing was [ __ ] uh
proprietary [ __ ] secret
how they [ __ ] programmed that took a
while for somebody to figure out well no
the guy
the kid that figured it out was like 18
or 19 years old he figured it out in one
night how to do it on the pc
yeah but he yeah how to do it on pc yeah
but
the reason why that happened is because
looking and nintendo wouldn't tell
anybody how they [ __ ] did that
right well yeah that's like well a lot
of companies are like that if they
figure out one thing that's like
proprietary information
you can't like figure it out uh karen
asked me can you make a playlist for
witching hour yes i can
um did you steal my pen no oh yeah yeah
you did i was like i'm sitting there
going where the [ __ ] is my pen
okay let me i i will i will write that
down right now
a witching hour list and i'll post it
somewhere
i might not do it today but i'll do it
sometime this week i promise
um but yeah so jenny to read stories
while you've fallen asleep
yeah yeah yeah all my creepy stories
i'm it's like i'm running out of my own
stories i probably gotta do more like
here just take that one because don't
don't use my one
yeah i didn't cut with you no i just
said don't use my pen that i'm actually
trying to use to write with
all right you ready to wrap it up you
didn't even see this movie
you didn't even see this movie no i have
not tried fallout 76
i actually heard that it sucked unless
they fixed it
you like fun you got fallout new vegas
and you got i got fallout 4 fallout new
vegas i got fallout 3
and i've never [ __ ] played i haven't
finished fallout 4. i'm still playing it
there's a lot of [ __ ] i
need to do i haven't done all the
expansion stuff like you know we're
going to the i did nuka world that was
it
yeah yeah i don't know you don't play
that quite as much as you use no because
you used to play it all the time
been out of it lately you've been going
i [ __ ] bought all the old doom games
i could get off a [ __ ] uh
xbox xbox one cause you could get like
doom
uh [ __ ] doom doom [ __ ] yeah
there's a brand new doom i don't have
the one before i have it
uh and then there's then i got all the
old ones the original dooms all the
[ __ ] i even got the original
wolfenstein
yeah got that i got the entire williams
arcade i got all the [ __ ]
sega i got i got sega genesis the whole
arcade [ __ ]
on xbox one a lot of those retro games
are there
i got some neo geo games i used to play
in the arcade got them on there like not
i think it's called 1945 or something
the [ __ ] there's you know just a
bunch of although what's funny is that
they're
they're not quite as fun as they were
nothing is
no no when you get old
they've kind of lost the mystique you
know what i'm talking about you know
you know more about video games now yeah
you know and you're like oh i remember
this game you put up with it for a
little bit but you just don't care
like joust you can play joust a little
bit but then after about 15 minutes you
don't care
yeah you know you know the game's not
going to go anywhere it's just going to
do that [ __ ] forever
i used to go over to like the
convenience store against my grandma's
house and play that
yeah video games like in the back room
i even have discs of tron which i love
that with the original controls but
to try to play it on a [ __ ] xbox
controller it's not the same
well see that's the thing i i played so
many games in the arcade
and then for and then i played them on
nintendo and sega to a lesser extent
like i played sonic the hedgehog a lot
when it came out and stuff
but it's been so long since i played a
video game like on a console
that it would take me a really long time
i can't even figure because we watch
movies and
you know and [ __ ] on our on the xbox so
it's like i can't even remember all the
[ __ ] buttons and triggers and [ __ ] on
the like what they do on that
to control the movies it took me like
for [ __ ] ever to figure that out well
because every single
everything is different like if you're
watching shutter like or
if you're watching youtube or if you're
watching tubey or if you're watching a
blu-ray
it's like the buttons do slightly
different things like depending on what
you're doing
so it's like i can never really remember
so it's like and i keep pushing the
trigger and being like oh [ __ ] what did
i do
and then you know it's so i i don't know
i don't know if i just have the time or
the inclination
to it's like i i watch you play fallout
and
stuff and i'm like oh that looks kind of
fun like maybe i should get into that
but it's like i just don't have the time
or the inclination to like figure out
how to use the controller and and then i
would probably just play it and not get
anything else done
and then i would be mad at myself it's
saying that fallout 76 is [ __ ]
fixed now but i think you have to have a
[ __ ] live internet connection you
have to
subscribe to it i don't think it's i
don't think it's like the rest of the
fallouts where you can just [ __ ] play
it i think it's multiplayer i think it's
like a multi-player it's not it's like
up in the cloud
yeah well i feel like everything's kind
of going that way isn't
yeah i guess i like to i like to
actually be the only one in there
yeah it's like i don't want a bunch of
random [ __ ] like running around
my game world get the [ __ ] out
i don't want you here i just want robots
in here
it's like i don't want to be in the real
world yeah yeah like that's like the
whole point i don't want a bunch of real
people walking around and they're
playing with me god damn it
that was another thing that they talked
about too on that uh
on that last uh episode of high score
was the the advent of multiplayer which
was also the guys
that did wolfenstein doom that was the
first because you couldn't
um they said you could before that you
can only do multiplayer
like if it was a real simple game like
chess or if
um there were there were games where
people had to take turns you know what i
mean because everybody had modems back
then
yeah um so so those guys also were the
first ones to figure out how to do
actual like multiplayer
where there were you know two people and
you could shoot at each other and [ __ ]
like that and it would
like work in real time i'm saying it's
free on game flip pass and you can play
on your own
yeah maybe i'll check it out one yeah
maybe i'll check it out there's another
one that
[ __ ] i'll probably release they
really [ __ ] it up everybody hated it
then they went back and fixed it and it
was [ __ ] great but i can't get it on
xbox one anymore and that was aliens
colonial marines
that looks like a kick-ass game yeah
when it came when it first came out
[ __ ] it frustrated people because it
had a lot of glitches and
everybody lost it it bombed but i got it
for i got it
through steam i was planted on a [ __ ]
uh little
um laptop that i had at the time
and i was having [ __ ] fun with it
multiplayer with a bunch of other guys
in there we were defending ourselves
from this [ __ ] wave after wave of
these [ __ ] alien
of xenomorphs and we had the [ __ ]
automatic [ __ ] guns we'd set them up
just right and [ __ ] get the weapons
that we wanted and
just we would just really barricade
ourselves into one room and just defend
one door
one of the things we were trying to do
but you had to go out to go get [ __ ]
in between waves so it sometimes it
wouldn't work out that way
but i really liked the single player and
the multiplayer on
aliens colonial marines they need to
[ __ ] re-release that
that'd be really good i just heard that
there was did
now this could be like totally wrong but
i just heard that there was a new game
or a newish game that just came out that
was like
lovecraft based like another new
lovecraft one i haven't looked i don't
know about it
like i said i'm not big up on like stuff
so it's usually if i'm on a blog that's
other like entertainment like music and
movies and stuff sometimes they'll like
talk about new video game releases and
so i'll see it out of the corner of my
eye
but i thought that was like a new
lovecraft thing and i was like oh that
sounds intriguing
because like i said i always kind of
like i like horror-based games like
scary games you know
yeah i always felt like i should get not
very many of them though i know that's
which is weird because i don't know i i
always kind of thought maybe i should
get into like silent hill or something
like that because that looked kind of
creepy
i was whatever happened with that game
that you were supposed to be able to
play
on your phone that was supposed to like
make your house into like a haunted
house
like you would you would go through your
house like and look at the [ __ ]
phone and then be like [ __ ] scary
[ __ ] popping out at you and you had to
like kill it
yeah whatever happened with that i don't
know i haven't i hadn't heard about that
for a couple of years because that's
like oh that looks badass that looks
like it's really fun
we can creep around the house and play
that [ __ ] i'm gonna see if you go on
another lockdown maybe i'll bite the
bullet and invest the xbox
xbox one i really like it uh yeah you
might as well get it the the lockdowns
are going to be from here on out
the rest of your life they're going to
try it they're going to try it oh yeah
watch
watch it it benefits them it would help
them reduce the population and all their
schemes are falling apart anyway
and so they're just trying to adjust to
the new economic realities
of that of a society in which people
just stay home forever
and they just bring [ __ ] to your door
like the matrix instead of being a damn
pod
with a virtual reality you're just in
your house watching a damn screen that's
what they want
that way you they don't want you running
around driving cars and
[ __ ] up their atmosphere and having
too many children and i don't want you
drinking and there's no reason for these
cities
a city is a future dead mall it's going
to go just like those malls
that's all city is is a mall that's what
it is
and then you know the commercial real
estate there's no reason for commercial
real estate
new york's fall apart because it's
mostly commercial real estate
you don't have to go to work to work you
ditch it from home
and then the company makes more profit
because they don't have to [ __ ] rent
that building
and they found out this is true it's not
tom talking out his [ __ ] ass
these companies looked at the bottom
line and they found out that
employee pro productivity went up when
they stayed home to work
not down it went up and then they told
him that was going to happen yeah and
then they realized
well [ __ ] then why are they here and why
we have this building
so then they book a huge amount of their
[ __ ] overheads
would vanish if they could get rid of
that [ __ ] office building
office buildings are [ __ ] obsolete
and when those out when those office
buildings go away guess what goes away
everything that's downtown you say well
why would that go away
the mall was a small replacement
for downtown it was downtown but covered
with ac
in it that's what it is amazon destroyed
that
now high bandwidth and everyone able to
stream
and to do everything from home will get
rid of that downtown area
urban [ __ ] living is gonna be a thing
of the past
everything's going to go excerpts
suburbs and rural because
you'll save money you can have that big
downtown
new york job and [ __ ] be working it
in a [ __ ] mississippi where you're
[ __ ]
spending 350 a month on rent for a giant
house
why the [ __ ] would you need to go to new
york so all of the [ __ ] opportunities
are now democratized
it doesn't matter where you are and the
system's
trying to figure out how to handle that
because
a lot of rich people are going to lose
their [ __ ]
ass and that's what all this paddock's
about
okay i'm getting off my soapbox they're
just getting wet
i'm gonna finish it wrap it up this way
people they're getting what they deserve
that's what's happening they're just
getting what they deserve
okay but you should say well how we got
off on that was yeah
xbox well the xbox i actually like i
said i don't play video games but it's
actually really useful for other [ __ ]
too
i mean you know we watch blu-rays on it
we like you can i watch shutter on it i
watch 2b
on it i watch youtube on it i watch
everything on it so you know you can use
it for other [ __ ] too and you can play
games on it it's super fun you can rent
movies through there and all that [ __ ]
my friend my friend steve who is a
[ __ ] biochemist from the university
of michigan and [ __ ] motherfucker's a
genius
all right he's worked for drug companies
he has his own software company doing
flight simulations and everything
he just had a kid and uh [ __ ]
he was just saying that about schools
there's no reason for school
you know what i mean if you can do
public school from home streaming then
that means you can do a private school
from home streaming
and those [ __ ] teachers unions are
gonna [ __ ] a [ __ ] brick
when they realize that they're all out
of jobs
uh they're gonna go the way amc everyone
will be able to get a badass education
of their choice right across the
internet
and it won't matter because these
degrees and [ __ ]
they won't matter because those were
only for big corporations and jobs and
[ __ ]
and that's all vanishing everyone's
going to [ __ ] make their own living
from home
every [ __ ] it'll be just like in the
it's going to be
just like in the [ __ ] medieval era
after the fall of [ __ ] uh uh serfdom
you have all the serfs just [ __ ]
making proto capitalism at home by
making little products and selling it
from their home but now they have the
the world is their marketplace because
of this bandwidth it's just a game
changer
people have not really wrapped their
minds around how much the world
has just changed in the past couple
months
this is not going back yeah i mean it's
changed a lot of this but you know it's
it was going to happen anyway yeah [ __ ]
will shake out in some ways it's
probably
for the better yeah i mean it's not good
that everybody had to get a disease for
that to happen but it's like it's
it's better maybe in the sense that it
was going that way anyway
it's the fact that it happened faster
and like it's like ripping off a
band-aid kind of
yeah they're ripping that band-aid off
this is moving us for this is
i'm gonna this past few months
this pandemic has moved us into the
future another decade
that's it made it all a reality if that
didn't happen
a lot of that stuff it would have taken
its another decade for it to slowly
decline
i think because the banks would have
kept pumping money into these loser
businesses
like emc thinking that that would come
back that's gone
the future is streaming i just got an
email that they were that they had
reopened actually
it's gone i'm just saying it's gone they
were in debt
and they were [ __ ] struggling before
the pandemic
all right now when they find out that
now that these movie studios find out
that they can make just as much money
just by releasing it online
okay with less overheads all right uh
that they'll be able to make money that
way
uh that the those studios were are going
to struggle
and and then fail emc will struggle and
fail from here on out
yeah oracle says i've worked from home
for about 20 years i i actually worked
from home
prior to this like for several years
prior to this i believe summer
summer 2016 i got laid off so i started
working from there just doing i
i stole some of the clients from like
the old graphic design place i used to
work
and uh i just said that freelance
clients lived off that not employment
then
my unemployment ran out a couple months
later and uh so then i just
we just started doing the show and i
started trying to sell my books and
yeah had a couple like rough times in
there but
the show shook out the show the books
shirts everything slowly
kind of worked out i would say
she might be making a little bit because
she gets all the show money i give all
the show money to her
it all goes bills anyway well yeah we
just we buy bills and i buy
stuff for the show like right you know
what i mean and um
so i would think that uh
we you you're probably making a little
bit more than you were when you worked
for other people you're definitely
happier
yeah because it's nice not having to get
up and go someplace yeah
in the morning that i don't necessarily
or having a boss breathing down your
neck or
now you're not worried about losing a
job because you have your own job
yeah you know so you're not dependent on
other people it's just a better way to
go
i mean and you can do it with anything i
mean they got guys putting together
models of the goddamn starship
enterprise and putting [ __ ]
led effects in them and painting them
and making five of them at a time and
selling them [ __ ] off the internet
for seven eight hundred dollars a piece
you know what i mean that's [ __ ]
five grand a month making the star trek
the starship enter [ __ ] prize well
yeah as long as you got people out there
that
pay for them i mean you know you could
you know so you just you got to take
something you like to do and learn how
to [ __ ] turn that into a living i
mean yeah
you get you get i'm an ex i'm an old
school [ __ ]
salesman you give me an internet
connection i'll figure out some kind of
way to make money
i'll just sell something yeah i'll grab
[ __ ] fine garbage and
sell that [ __ ] put that [ __ ] up on an
ebay store
look at that [ __ ] it's a fine work of
art make some toast with jesus
there's a lot faces a lot of [ __ ]
vent if you know if you got a good eye
for it you go man that's the [ __ ]
vintage clothes man that's vintage
lucite lamp
yeah you know what i mean those little
hippie people that like that [ __ ] from
the old 60s and [ __ ]
trying to recreate some that vintage
look and [ __ ] i'll sell that [ __ ] for a
hundred bucks
i was looking up lose sight they had
dudes that wanted thousands of dollars
for those lose sight lamps
yeah and everybody used to have them
these they just junk
well now it's like kitsch so yeah it's
kitchy [ __ ] and if you want to do like a
retro look you kind of want to have a
[ __ ] real thing
yeah and honestly like sometimes you
want to do like um
you know like a period piece movie
that's like set back in the 70s or
something like that you would need to
buy that [ __ ] to like dress your sets
you know yeah
i'm just saying there's just so many
opportunities out there
if you're if you've got the right
mindset yeah
and then oracle says plus i get to play
with our cats occasionally during the
day yeah see we
we are home with pookie all the time so
she doesn't miss us she doesn't you know
she she gets like the oracle mom she
says she loves it because no more
pantyhose yeah i thought it was i
thought oracle man was a man
that might be a man man with pantyhose
nobody likes patios
yeah mega badger says i can say it all
honestly i've loved working from home
and my quality of life really improved
yeah i you know it's like i i really
that's it's something i always wanted to
do like i said it's still work and i
work
a lot more hours than i used to i mean
it used to be that i would work eight
nine hours ten hours
and then come home and be like [ __ ] i
don't wanna think about work anymore and
now it's more like 10 to 12 hours
and i'm and then like in the evenings
like a lot of times we're watching
movies to review or documentaries
about like the topic that we're gonna do
next week so we're still we're kind of
working
all the time mostly yeah i mean i'm not
really usually
but most of the time it's like i'm doing
[ __ ] i enjoy like you know i'm reviewing
books so i have to read a book that i'm
gonna review which i
you know which i like and i would have
done anyway the movies that we're
watching most of our movies we would
have watched anyway
so you know it's not dominick's going
he's an engineer he's got a he can't
work from home
yeah there's going to be certain jobs
that are different infrastructure people
they have to go out there with their
hands and go fix [ __ ]
and that's good though because those
kind of people will be even
more valuable what what i'm mostly
talking about this working from home
ship
is the white collar stuff and creative
people it's all going to be from home
yeah the white collar in white collar
jobs are
they're out they're not going to exist
in the same form that exists
now it's not going to look that like
that that came from a 1940s 1930s
50s mentality where you had to show up
you had a physical supervisor making
sure everybody [ __ ] worked
yeah that that kind of you don't need
that anymore yeah
that's actually inefficient now they
have to commute to and from
that's what it's extra energy expended
you know what i mean and money and
wasted time
they can do that work from home yeah
oracle said my husband would be
surprised to hear he's been married to a
man for so long yeah
especially because our anniversary is
next week congratulations
celtic angel says i wish i could work
from home but at least i work night
shift
i actually used to work night shift at
uh at a newspaper
and um i actually really like that
because it's it's much nicer
not having like tons of people around
not having managers around it was just
kind of us and the creative department
and the dudes that that ran the press
and that was it
so it was like nice and you know a
couple of like cleaners and stuff
yeah so it was like really nice in this
big like creepy building
yeah it's funny because people are still
listening to she worked for a newspaper
and people still listen to newspapers
and
the news agencies you know the gray lady
and everything those things are just a
[ __ ]
hollow shell of what they once were
those buildings are mostly empty
and they're not i'm running on a
skeleton crew
because news is obsolete what do you
what do you need newscasters for people
are [ __ ] posting [ __ ] right off their
phones of what happened
right on the damn youtube you don't need
somebody to tell you what happened you
can see what happened
so the whole game's changed yeah the
whole game's changed
and and you know what's funny the news
is just selling a narrative anyway
whatever their client want whatever
their client wants
the story to be that's how they'll spin
it you know
so [ __ ] all that man like those riots i
was watching the [ __ ] riots and the
shooting that happened at the riots last
night
in that little [ __ ] town somewhere i
don't even became pronounced it started
with a k
i don't need anybody to tell me that
[ __ ] they ran up on that dude he
blasted three of them i saw it
it's funny get out of me and i didn't
find out about that through cnn or msnbc
i found out about it from a youtuber
that mentioned it so
and and that youtuber has [ __ ] over a
million [ __ ] followers
and in his head he gets nearly a million
hits per video
that's far bigger than [ __ ] cnn and
msnbc what they get per hour
so it's just the game has [ __ ]
changed the old way
of doing things is gone you know it's
it's social media now that's what's
driving everything and a good thing this
is now
the open square it's that it's it's
the people's media it's the town square
it's freedom of press each person is a
reporter
that's what a free press is about
okay glenn asked is it your birthday now
or soon jenny my
birthday is actually september 26th so
it's that oh a month from today actually
um
and uh as i said the over that weekend
that's when the strange realities online
conference is going to be
i'm not sure what my um what my time
slot is but it's going to be something i
don't know if it's the 25th to 26th or
the 27th but i'm giving like an hour
presentation at that
so you know i run the commercials for it
sometimes during the
main shows and we also have the
commercial on our
channel yeah so yeah um if you have like
i said i don't know if like shutter
australia has this
movie or not because i know that the
movies between like australia uk and
us are different but um unless you have
a vpn
yeah like i said unless you have a vpn
then you can probably watch whatever
[ __ ] shutter you want because you
know
but uh yeah i really really liked this
one so if you watch it like and you
liked it too or if you didn't like it
just tell me what you thought of it i
just really dug it and i don't i can't
really exactly put my finger on why i
liked it so much
um it was probably like a combination of
things but i don't know i thought it was
really good
so uh yeah we're probably not going to
we'll stream again on
saturday night our regular big episode
should kind of be a fun one we're doing
more
i guess it's kind of true crime but it's
like a historical
which one is this i'm not gonna tell you
yeah
well this is going to be the last one
that is not going to be like a pole
choice you know what i mean like after
this one
all of the subsequent ones are going to
be like poll
right because i'm crowd sourcing the
topics i'm just going to give like five
topics and people can
vote on what ones they want us to do all
right so we will uh you know tomorrow
witching hour goes up friday uh movie
retrospective goes up
and then we will see you guys again live
on saturday probably at 5 p.m eastern
standard time as usual
so until then we will talk to you later
bye